il faut aller la chercher au bout d'un
quartier populaire du nord de la ville
et quand on arrive devant elle impose le
respect la statue du mahatma gandhi
trône devant le radar krishna un temple
hindou fréquenté par les soixante mille
indiens du portugal
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est le diwali le nouvel en
inde où une cérémonie un manque à bhl
pour nine arrate hilal et les cinq mille
indiens de confession hindoue du
portugal
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mahina est arrivé avec son mari au
portugal il y a près de 30 ans le choc
culturel
elle garde de nombreux souvenirs au
début quand nous sommes arrivés c'était
difficile ce monde me regardait avec mon
saric s'interrogeait mais maintenant ils
sont habitués et même les portugais le
porte pendant le carnaval
après la nourriture de l'esprit
direction la salle du repas pour un
festin exclusivement végétarien au menu
pas l'akp anr aux épinards dalo
lentilles écuries de pommes de terre
c'est difficile parce que nous sommes
dans un pays où il n'y a pas beaucoup de
végétariens
il ya plein d'endroits où il n'y a que
de la viande
et des fois c'est très dur parce que des
amis organisent des fêtes à ces endroits
où on veut aller
on reste là bas sans pouvoir manger ou
alors il faut manger avant le
lendemain matin on retrouve naïna et
quand on a une à ne prit pas elle donne
la charité depuis neuf ans elles seront
deux fois par semaine au centre krishna
au coeur de la ville
c'est ici qu'elle concocte en chansons
des petits plats végétariens pour
distribuer aux sans abri de lisbonne
selon notre livre sacré parmi toutes les
bonnes actions
la charité donné des vêtements aller au
temple le plus important c'est de donner
à manger à ceux qui en ont besoin
et avant la distribution c'est toujours
le même rituel on demande à krishna sa
bénédiction
ce qu'ils vont manger permet de changer
leur mentalité ça les purifie fiq
politique à moins qu avant il y avait
des alcooliques ou des drogués j'aime ça
les a changé maintenant il chante avec
nos avoirs
[Musique]
la distribution de nourriture se fait à
santa polonia près de la gare centrale
lieu de rendez vous des plus démunis
tous les lundis ils sont des dizaines à
venir se remplir l'estomac et se
réchauffer le coeur
j'aime beaucoup venir ici je suis
contente ça me rend joyeuse de les voir
heureux et de les voir manger
[Musique]
vous aurez encore un peu plus s'il vous
plaît vous aimez ma cuisine bien sûr
bien sûr
une bonne action pour naïna synonyme de
reconnaissance envers le pays qui
l'accueillent
[Musique]
maintenant j'habite ici c'est mon pays
avec qui il faut que jade ici et non pas
ailleurs non c'est dans ce pays que je
gagne ma vie donc c'est là que je dois
aider les gens à qui
[Musique]
ils sont
et
puis tout d'un coup je suis contente
très contente
parce qu'en plus de donner à manger je
leur apprends aussi à chanter et si
maicon pas est ce que coûte la pma la
culture hindoue et très généreuse comme
on me dit mon époque personne ne
distribuait de nourriture dans la rue on
mourait de faim
aujourd'hui dans un portugal assommés
par la crise ce sont les immigrés
hindous qui aide les portugais en grande
difficulté une situation encore
inimaginable il y a quelques années
seulement
mais avant de distribuer des repas dans
la rue les indiens de lisbonne doivent
remplir le porte monnaie et il y en a
pour qui ça marche
bienvenue dans la zone industrielle de
pryor velho c'est ici que monsieur quand
il a choisi d'établir le siège de son
entreprise il y à 27 ans on va voir
notre salle d'expo
lui c'est un de mes frères on est 50 ou
feint businessman il a trouvé le bon
filon il importe puis revend des cadeaux
promotionnels
ça c'est fabriqué en inde sa sé sak
aussi sont faits en inde
les entreprises mettent leur logo sur le
sac mais ils offrent à leurs clients
à 63 ans monsieur quand il a fait du
chemin il gère aujourd'hui avec ses
quatre frères cette entreprise familiale
et chapote 38 employés un succès bien
mérité après 51 ans de travail acharné
gbagbo j'ai commencé à travailler à
l'âge de 12 ans
mon père avait une petite boutique
et c'est là derrière le comptoir avec
lui que j'ai commencé à bosser
ce souvenir là je ne l'oublierai jamais
parents ont toujours transmis les
valeurs essentielles
travailler honnêtement ne trompait
personne préserver l'image de
l'entreprise
ici bien évidemment le business se fait
entre l'inde et le portugal
histoire d'optimiser jusqu'au bout les
avantages de la double culture
pour faire des affaires entre les deux
pays il est indispensable de parler les
deux langues
à lisbonne tous les indiens ont étudié
un jour ou l'autre à santo antonio
d'oscar valero sts
c'est dans cette proche banlieue que les
premiers indiens sont arrivés dans les
années 70 au milieu des barres
d'immeubles trône le temple de shiva
monsieur quand ils allaient le président
de cet établissement
lâcher grâce
ici on enseigne le gujarat y une langue
indienne
[Musique]
le l'objectif principal c'est de
transmettre notre langue maternelle
pour eux quand ils seront plus grands
qu'ils sachent d'où ils viennent
ils connaissent leurs racines
c'est bien évidemment aussi la culture
de leurs parents grands parents et
arrière grands parents
s'ils ne font pas ce cas les
comprendrons pas d'où ils viennent
ils ne comprendront pas notre culture
ici on leur enseigne comment être de
meilleurs indien dans un pays étranger
et à garder notre identité
[Musique]
vecteur de leur identité la langue
gujrat y est aujourd'hui parler par
quelque 46 millions de personnes en inde
35 % de la population est analphabète
mais ici sur les bancs de l'école les 50
marmots savent déjà pratiquement tous
lire et écrire en portugais et en
bougera ti
[Musique]
une nouvelle star à la sauce bollywood
présidé par monsieur quand hilal
[Musique]
et les volontaires se succèdent avec
plus ou moins de talent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vois bollywood comme une façon
positive de promouvoir la culture
indienne dans le monde entière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
même les portugais sont accoutumés à
bollywood
les films la musique les reportages les
danses aussi
et même les telenovelas sont diffusées
ici à la télé
[Musique]
allez
même si les indiens de lisbonne ont du
mal à pousser la chansonnette
ils ont indéniablement trouver le bon
tempo pour réussir leur intégration et
animer les nuits portugaise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]